l'heure est grave l'heure est grave
puisque jean michel maire là on joue
dans le jeu des vérités merci thomas tu
peux rester de seconde main de sakho
nord on sait qu'entre vous et eric
naulleau
c'est extrêmement tendue et pour cause
il ya quelques semaines un mot a mis le
feu aux poudres sur votre relation avec
eric naulleau
j'ai ici je vous lis des mots que vous
l'avez écrit encore dont j'ai par
exemple que je vais dire aux
téléspectateurs
si tu as une tronche à faire rater une
couvée de singe j'en ai un autre vous
dis-je en est un autre qui est encore
pire que vous avez créés et eric
naulleau qui ont voulu écrivait des
petits mots doux pendant l'émission en
place hier dans l'émission le mot le
voit si t'es comme le lui de couilles tu
sers à rien jean michel prêtre
la guerre est déclarée ont pensé que
c'était terminé mais en rallye
car continue s'est pas excusé on regarde
pas mais vous que nous
[Musique]
me réjouis pour quatre ans
fico
[Musique]
je vous dis et je le dis aux
téléspectateurs on peut plus continuer
comme ça on ne peut plus continuer cette
émission avec deux chroniqueurs qui se
détestent h escalade de l'horreur sur
haïti au psg à deux fois avant de le
calmer vous si j'étais vous je me ferais
tout petit pourquoi cette guerre entre
vous pourquoi ces messages de haine
comment tout ça commence et je pensais
vraiment que c'était derrière nous mais
non malheureusement c'est devant et les
deux se détestent de plus en plus je
vous le dis vous en rigolait peut-être
mais moi je ne rigole pas ça m'attriste
ça me peine ça me crachent fish s'est
achevée chaque piste et dès qu'elles
résident vers 2 heures par verre de
crash fut chez asus à dire premier
groupe ça fait des crashs dans mon coeur
ta gueule mais vous lis ce n'est pas
tout plus dur que les mots il ya les
paroles regarder la tension entre vous
et eric naulleau
c'est insoutenable si tu regardes tu
comprends ce qu'ils sont
[Musique]
les interventions du génial mais ils ont
pu
témoin j'ai oublié une présence et un
charisme
[Musique]
annie physique
dans l'ue seules mères cheffes vous
noterez quand même que je suis un milieu
historique de série mais on s'en fout là
alors team eric outin jambi pour moi il
n'ya qu'une team c'est la team bmp
famille
oui famille family famille de l'eia
qu'un femme street
cela me couche à jean-michel lyrique je
ne sais pas d'où vient votre haine mais
aujourd'hui devant les téléspectateurs
de tmp
j'ai besoin qu'on brise la glace c'est
beau ça et les salles où on dirait mon
cul voilà merci choses à rennes nice et
s'il venait là elle me fous un peu
1 mettez vos lunettes mettez vos gonds
et comme dans le grand frère ouais c'est
cyril le grand frère mois il vient le
bouffon s'il vous plaît soyez courtois
dit les choses si les trouviez brusque
là tous les jours où tout le monde peut
venir que deux fois par semaine et
remplacerait merci eric walter
[Musique]
mario
ces marionnettes elle était quand on
sait pas revivre cette situation même
aussi je trie avec jean-michel les
cherry en avait tiré les leçons
vous allez nous dire tu déjà et d'où
vient cette querelle
d'où vient cette haine d'où vient cette
rivalité
d'où vient cette crise n'a qu'à langues
sont là danois souvient s'être usmar moi
j'en fais pas une question de jeu peut
parler en premier pas non mais faut vous
qu'il faut déjà qu'est ce qui sépare un
homme très brillant fond c'est parce que
je suis là depuis la première il ya
beaucoup de gens qui aimeraient bien
être autour de la table et je trouve que
ça se mérite est toujours natale il
suffit pas de dire j'ai écrit j'ai lu
des bouquins pour mériter d'être de là
il connaît rien aux médias donc tout
simplement y en a déjà mais la télé où
il a déjà joué une fois aux coulisses je
regarde pas la télé qu'antillais votre
pique et dites-vous les choses eric
dites ce que vous avez à reprocher à
jean michel m'étais bien vos lunettes et
dit oui comme dans le grand frère on va
briser la glace
c'est parti la première chose que j'ai à
reprocher et saint jean michel c'est que
s'il bossait tape avec la même énergie
après qui tape la même énergie qui lui
était à lécher les bottes d'hanouna il
aurait déjà acheté chez 8
voilà ce que j'ai à dire pour gagner
c'est ce que vous le reprocher je lui
reproche d'être un être pétri de
méchanceté prêt et il n'existe que par
la méchanceté s'il cessé d'être méchant
il cesserait d'exister
donc il est obligé de persévérer dans ce
maître jean-michel ouais je lui reproche
et je suis pas le seul dans cette
émission a jamais vouloir se déguiser en
même temps c'est pas très amincie les ja
tu me radier comme un trouble
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
eric à l'isic est souvent reproché à
jean michel aulas n'est pas un reproche
c'est un regret j'aurais dû garder tous
les papiers qu'il m'a fait passer parce
qu'il y en a qui sont exclues fort
embarrassante a girl qu'est ce que je
veux comme je veux
pourquoi pourquoi vous ne vous rendez
pas tous les deux mois vous ne vous
entendez pas tous les deux quelle est
votre version
ça va être très long l'émission serait
moi même façon c'est que il joue les
contestataires les les libertaires qui
bon clean et c'est qu'en fait c'est un
gros des citrouilles qui passe son temps
à nous balancer des boîtiers que je
écrit dans les mythes souviens même pas
de droite ou m'affronter
[Rires]
je reproche un jean michel mr d'inventer
ses anecdotes et que ces anecdotes sont
à peu près aussi fausse que ses cheveux
ceux qui ne voient là ce que j'avais à
dire c'est assez joli
là on éloigne paris première de sa
balance à paris c'est plus tellement
intel aux mutuelles alors juste
j'aimerais qu'on vienne au fond du
problème qu'est ce que vous reprochez à
jean michel maire pourquoi vous ne vous
aimez pas on ne comprend peut pas
commencer
non seulement c'est très rapide c'est sa
présence tout court je reproche pourquoi
parce qu'il sert à rien c'est comme le
inkling sert à rien ce que j'y connais
rien en télé dit nocture gonelle bien
sûr qu'ils les connais tu regardes tu
regardes les émissions de tv on parle tu
as regardé les matchs regarder marseille
venus répondre à tes questions jean macé
[Applaudissements]
si vous regardez à la pause sur une
seule question je n'avais rien alors les
chéris mais je crois que jean-michel
mois jean michel mercier était avec vous
avez été mais il a été mis sur écoute
elle jamais jamais sous des apparences
un peu comme ça ils la ramènent je pense
qu'il se sent mis en danger par tout le
monde
regard nouveau venu tout d'un coup ça
persévérante les choisit la première
victoire c'est nous et c'est bizarre la
vie des chroniqueurs on coule jamais
laisser les nanas on avait été coupé
après on n'a pas d'accord merci
qu'est ce qu'ils écoutent ya des
techniciens qui peuvent glisser dessus
de benjamin castaldi est ce que vous
comprenez la méchanceté de jean michel
maire envers eric n'aurait pas elle
m'étonne parce que c'est un garçon que
j'aime beaucoup aussi je trouve a priori
comme ça avait l'air ouvert aux autres
qu'est ce qui s'est passé ensuite
est ce qu'ils se battent pour une femme
je ne sais pas là mais tout ça n'est pas
catégorisé ory le confirme jean michel
était un peu le séducteur de l'équipe le
beau gosse de l'équipe etc
j'aurai le camp eric est arrivé eric
avec son bras sa culture sa prestance et
c'est tout d'un coup les ce qu'il est
joli ont commencé à discuter avec lui et
du coup je me suis senti un peu gâchée
[Applaudissements]
je ne sais pas si on va en voir l'écran
mais le faire du visage va pas bien mais
le rythme pourquoi vous comprenez
pourquoi il ya aussi méchant avec eric
moi je pense que c'est clairement un
délit de faciès
ben c'est ça je crois que ça ne lui
revient pas je comprends ces mots
simples c'est moche oui mais qu'ont-ils
moi je comprends pas du tout totalement
du côté d'éric il est là dans son coin
et dit rien est fait de mal à personne
je sais pas pourquoi tu lui en veux
comme ça il en branle pas une mais toi
non plus jean
[Rires]
jamais vraiment vraiment non non moi je
comprends pas non plus je pense que tout
le monde à sa place c'est vrai qu'il ya
eric il parle pas beaucoup parfois dans
l'émission que moi je parle pas non plus
moi je comprends pas par leoni des
choses intéressantes et ses lectures et
jean-eric avoue penser ça est déjà lourd
éric et lola la petite était mal en
prime une balance un glaçon à la tronche
la petitesse du même contrat plein
donnait la parole alors oui je me dois
quand même de défendre eric c'est bien
pour moi
doucement des questions là c'est un
grand chelem là et rigoureux vos
chroniqueurs tutu avant que le fait
qu'effectivement sera à nouveau
chroniqueur est ça qui me dérange
moi tu es adorable avec moi donc je
comprends pas pourquoi de cette semaine
donc il ya quelque chose entre vous bas
juste mais la bise à lui l'asie c'est
tout simple à un petit alors mais
surtout que j'ai été bien accueilli par
tout le monde juste
est-ce que sauf j'aimerais j'aimerais
que ce soir qu'on mette fin à ces à
bisous quoi bah oui alors ça c'est en
photo by j'aimerais que ce soir vous
disiez je ne reproche voilà je ne ferai
plus de mots à eric la jeune lena qui
s'excuse ou les avoir passé des noms
mais derrière pas d'excusés au contraire
on est une balance dans ma famille je
vais vous dire j'ai tout les cas là il
ya un code d'honneur de moi qu'il arrive
j'avais tous les mots puisque j'ai
toutes les caméras qui récupérer les
boues mais moi je vous disais pape a
lancé oui messieurs les élus de donneurs
au canada mais je vous le dis donc t'as
n'avait pas vous n'avez pas à lui
demander de s'excuser de m'informer sur
des choses ça c'est sûr donc voilà donc
je vous le dis surtout tu arrives c'est
l'autorité de cyril qui tu avais
interdit de recommencer vrai rush tu
continueras très grave ce profil est ce
que ce soit vous pouvez dire parce qu'on
est pressé là on à valence ton poste
important
je vous le dis est ce que ce soir vous
pouvez le dire c'est une émission
d'intello n'était pas premier coeur le
malawi
reste assez d'essence et y en a il va
rentrer chez lui en a cure et c'est
aujourd'hui qu'ils rendent chez lui et
c'est jamie s'écoute pas légal a
submergé ne les lanaudois du ferrasse
makinson bah non en signe d'apaisement
je retire ce que j'ai vécu jusque là ces
gens si je suis bon georges apprécié le
geste voilà et s'il fait un pas vers moi
donc je vais faire un pas vers la bravo
voilà et donc j'aime bien les plus
mettre un coup de boule
nous partons pas nous passer